i'm here with our exercise guru ben
eater hi sal and we are looking at this
module you've made called exploring mean
and median and let's see what it says
arrange the five orange points so these
are the orange points right over here on
the number line so the arithmetic mean
is negative 0.1 and arithmetic mean is
really kind of what we traditionally you
view as the average the average you you
add up the numbers and divide by the
number that you have right and that the
median is 2.5 and 2.5 is essentially the
the middle number if you have an odd
number of numbers which we do here
or it would if you have an even number
of numbers it's the it's the it's the
arithmetic mean of the middle two
numbers it's really going right halfway
between the middle two numbers and
they're both ways of measuring kind of
central tendency right
and the distance between adjacent tick
marks is one so this is like so this one
right over here is zero this is one this
is two this is negative one this is
negative two and so the whole point
what's what's the point of this exercise
the point well you said they're both
ways of measuring central tendency um
but what we can see here is that they
don't always give you the same answer
um so we're being asked to see an
arithmetic
arithmetic mean of negative 0.1 and a
median of 2.5 those are very different
numbers yeah so how can you take five
points and say the central tendency is
negative point one right and the central
tendency is two point five right and
there's just different ways there's
different ways of measuring it and
sometimes one way is better exactly
exactly and you kind of have to know and
immediately i was just starting to play
with and you see you can if i take this
the highest number here and i change it
i can change the mean but it didn't
change the median because the middle
number is still this middle number no
matter what what's going on out here and
that's why actually the median
tends to be viewed as a better measure
when you have outliers when you have
really really really you know large
values or or really really really small
values the median is a little bit more
robust so if like this thing just some
crazy large number the median didn't
change much right even though this this
one number being large took the whole
the whole arithmetic mean up the same
thing out here if i had an outlier over
here
it doesn't change the median so in this
case it's asking us a mean of negative
0.1 and a median of 2.5 those are very
far apart right so you might expect a
lot of outliers right so when we're done
you probably would think a lot of the
points are going to be closer to 2.5
let's let's think about this so let me
let me get the median first so the
median is just a middle number right and
so and here there's five numbers so the
middle number literally has to be 2.5
one of those outs has to be on so let me
make the middle number 2.5
so that gets me to 2
2.5 that's got to be there you're
looking at the mean there oh sorry yeah
yeah sorry i'm looking at the mean 2.5
is the median
median is 2.5
and now and now i want to get the mean
at negative a zero point negative one or
negative zero point one so let me start
making this take see what i can do to
make
negative
mean still is not
so let's see
i mean look there you go here we go
there we go so let me check my answer
yeah so this you see that there are
yeah which of those numbers do you think
better represents the central tendency
yeah well
you i don't know you don't know in this
case right
it's a uh either one is so let's see if
they were all grouped and there was a
couple of outliers then the median
probably would have been better yeah and
there might be different ways to arrange
those dots yeah too and you can play
with them yeah now that'd be interesting
let me check
i got it right let's do another one
next question
all right arranger 10 dots okay same
thing we want the mean 3.6 median at 6.
so let me think about the median first
so i want to get the middle number
middle number to
median at six huh so
the median
the median it's
the median is six
you need to drag one more dot over
because you're you're going to be
between the two middle numbers because
you have an even oh oh yes yes yes
you're right so we're the median is
taking the right right right right
so here we go median is now six yep very
good right i had to worry about middle
two numbers because i had an even number
that's right and now let me see the mean
i need to get to 3.6
the mean
i need to get two and i can't make this
one of the middle numbers it then will
distort my median
three
point i guess it can be one it can't get
yeah you can't go past that yeah yeah
so let's see i want to go to 3.6
3.6
gets me right over there there you go
there you go so here which of those
numbers do you think is a better central
tendency
i i would say the the median in this one
because these feel a little bit more
outlier-like right at least in this
situation the way i've we've set up this
distribution let's check the answer
that's satisfying get the smiley face
and you also have hints here someone has
trouble with it that's right and they
can actually show you maybe a different
way to do it yeah so you define the
median is a middle number
then you show
dragging points so let's see show an
example let's see so this is an example
okay this is an example where the median
and the mean are both six right so that
just puts half the points to the left of
the median half the points to the right
right right right right that makes sense
and then you can keep going but that
doesn't solve the problem no that's
so let's see and then you explain so you
just give a little more explanation
there and then finally you talk about
how you change this so that you can get
the mean of 3.6 so let's see if you show
that example so there you go so it just
moves a couple outliers outliers so
adjust the mean but then the median
doesn't change right very interesting